alors Thierry Samitier a été placé en
garde à vue ce mardi au commissariat du
centre à Paris pour agression et
harcèlement sexuel et ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est que une jeune femme donc de
43 ans a porté plainte en 2022 contre
lui pour pouvoir seulement et agressions
il y avait déjà eu des mains courantes
qui avaient été qui avait été déposé en
l'effet remonte en fait à 2018 et 2019
dans une pièce qui s'appelait Boeing
Boeing où il jouait avec trois actrices
et deux actrices déjà à l'époque avaient
fait une main courante c'était même mis
en arrêt maladie pour pour ne plus avoir
à faire à ce qu'elle disait être du
harcèlement il était assez précieux et
d'ailleurs à l'époque la pièce avait été
mis en suspens avait même été arrêté
parce que il ne pouvait plus continuer
dans ces conditions là
bah alors selon selon le dépôt de plate
il y avait plusieurs choses on lui
reproche d'abord d'être un peu
lourdingue de faire des commentaires un
peu
sexuels ensuite des tactile après la
personne qui a porté plainte raconte que
lors d'une répétition le 24 octobre 2018
elle est en train de se démaquiller dans
sa loge et puis elle était penchée pour
accéder au miroir et tout un coup
Thierry serait arrivé derrière elle et
aurait collé son sexe contre ses fesses
elle raconte ensuite qu'elle l'a repris
pourquoi tu as peur de moi
il aurait régalé de façon pervers
ensuite elle raconte que
pendant pendant les pièces en fait il
l'embrassait il
ignore rentrer la langue dans la bouche
de force alors que c'était pas prévu par
par évidemment par le metteur en scène
elle explique aussi qu'elle s'en est
plein au metteur Arsène qui à l'époque à
agi et a dit à remonter les bretelles de
Thierry Samitier sauf que ça ne s'est
pas ça ne s'est pas du tout calmé qui a
eu il y aurait eu d'autres faits
d'autres faits ou le corps avec des
pressions physiques etc et du coup les
la jeune femme ce serait mis en arrêt
maladie à ce moment-là le journal 20
minutes a rapporté la plante déposée par
la comédienne il a plus d'un an parce
qu'en avril 2022 voici ce qui en sont
Thierry Samitier ce serait montré
entreprenant dès le rencontre en
septembre 2018 en multipliant les
compliments parmi lesquels ta beauté me
trouble ça non excusez-moi voilà
excusez-moi désolé mais ça vous choque
ça non pour le moment non pour le moment
là dans ce que vous venez de dire
merci et ce serait montré également
alors ça oui
il va te dire ah voilà alors là oui
d'ailleurs il se serait montré également
très tactile rendant très mal à l'aise à
comédienne
il aurait regardé avec insistant sans
lui demander qu'est-ce qui nous arrive
sur quoi elle aurait souvent répondu bah
rien
très drôle la comédienne j'aime beaucoup
non non mais voilà là sur ça bon il est
lourd voilà
il se sera invité à plusieurs reprises
dans sa loge là voilà c'est là où ça
demande compliqué on lui collant son
sexe sur ses fesses la bloquant entre
lui et le miroir de sa loge ou en
tentant de l'embrasser de force en leur
placant contre un mur c'est ça le plus
important et comme vous avez dit essayer
de mettre sa langue à chaque fois dans
la bouche de la comédienne lorsqu'il
faut jouer des scènes de baisers il est
précisé dans la plante qu'il était
difficile de lui dire
non pendant que 500 personnes
regardaient la pièce voilà
moi et Thierry Samitier aurait dit à la
cliente moi moi je mets la langue la
plus haute lui répond bah oui Thierry tu
l'as fait avec moi la semaine dernière
tu as mis la langue maintenant tu
t'arrêtes selon la plus grande toujours
il l'aurait bloqué plusieurs fois dans
les couloirs en l'intimidant à raconter
également un rendez-vous avec le
producteur de la pièce comme vous avez
dit qui lui aurait conseillé de rester
en bon terme avec Thierry sanity il m'a
dit également que s'il devait choisir
entre le reste de la troupe et Samitier
son choix était fait ce serait Thierry
il voulait que je reste dans la pièce et
que je sois plus gentil avec Thierry qui
se plaint d'être mise à l'écart
j'étais très perturbé émotionnellement
de plus j'avais besoin de ce travail
j'avais deux enfants en bas âge j'avais
besoin d'argent je n'ai donc rien dit de
peur d'être viré de la pièce et un soir
il aurait menaçant lui affirmant qu'il
allait je cite l'écrabouiller et
auraient déposé une main courante dans
la foulée donc lui a déposé une main
courante et le truc c'est que le
producteur a essayé à un moment donné de
de trouver à notre acteur pour remplacer
Thierry Samitier sauf qu'il a demandé il
aurait demandé des des indemnités de
rupture de contrat trop importante qui
fait que finalement ils ont arrêté la
pièce tout court alors une décision a
été prise pour calmer les tensions
puisque Thierry a été changé de loge il
avait sa loge à l'étage et quelqu'un
devait le surveiller mais cette personne
ne pouvait pas rester près de lui H24
donc c'est un truc de fou ça par contre
cette même plaignante a raconté une
autre anecdote aux policier une fois il
nous a présenté sans vendre
celle qui avait déposé plainte contre
Luc Besson une fois qu'elle est partie
nous a dit à Marinelli et moi vous voyez
LTL qui dit qu'elle a été violée par
Besson et finalement il y a eu un
non-lieu
histoire voilà c'est vrai que un
non-lieu d'ailleurs sur l'affaire Luc
Besson et c'est bien de le préciser
également parce que c'est on profite de
cette affaire pour le préciser que voilà
Besson il y a eu vraiment un non-lieu
sur sur l'affaire dont il a été
comme ça il y avait une enquête de
Mediapart il y a quelques années et
notamment une habilleuse de la série nos
chers voisins celle qui l'a fait
connaître qui avait raconté à peu près
des faits similaires ou effectivement il
est très Lourdin il s'approche de la
personne il en l'a si lui souffle dans
le cou il embrasse alors que cette
personne lui dit clairement non alors
la pièce avait été arrêté donc en mars
2019 après les et ça arrive maladie des
comédiennes Franck Leboeuf était dans
cette pièce il confirme avoir été témoin
de comportement inapproprié de son
collègue il explique ce qu'il a vu j'ai
vu Alice sortir de scène en tremblant et
en disant attirer d'arrêter de mettre la
langue lors de leur scène de baiser j'ai
dit à Thierry mettez un grand malade toi
va falloir que tu t'arrêtes je sais que
je défends une association tu sais que
je défends une association qui lutte
contre les violences faites aux femmes
et Franck Leboeuf Dijon veut la
production car ils n'ont pas fait
grand-chose si ce n'est que de le sortir
des Loges cette pièce s'est arrêtée de
fans n'en pouvait plus de ses
agissements
c'est vrai que voilà donc le bœuf a pris
la parole là-dessus Vanina m'ont aussi
vous êtes avec nous vous êtes vous étiez
agent de Thierry Samitier vous avez
travaillé avec lui
quand vous entendez tout ça
est-ce que vous tombez des NU non je
tombe pas de nu parce que depuis 2019
c'est un peu la galère
moi je viens parce que j'étais son agent
artistique avant d'être son agent
artistique j'avais créé des liens
d'amitié or je vous dis honnêtement je
faisais 40 kilos de moins donc j'étais
quand même pas trop moche on n'a jamais
dragué
moi je viens
certes je n'étais pas sur les moments en
présence des faits mais vous par exemple
vous a jamais dragué tout ça ce que vous
disiez non alors si on va dire combien
de fois il m'a dit qu'on allait en
soirée ce soir tu fais ta bimbo parce
que je m'habiller plus serré j'ai une
grosse poitrine mais si on peut plus on
est dans le showbiz il va falloir
arrêter un petit peu le délire alors je
sais qu'il y a des faits qui sont vraies
mais je ne citerai pas de nom mais mon
grand-père qui est décédé qui était un
grand producteur
il avait 85 ans mais les actrices de 25
ans et 21 ans qui habitait chez lui ou
qui couchait avec lui elle savait pas
honte de coucher avec lui pour avoir
85 ans bien sûr mais bien sûr et je peux
vous le dire qu'il avait des Supers
Nanas pour devenir ça donne de l'espoir
mais Cyril c'est pas mais on va être
honnête vous claquer des doigts vous
avez plein de femmes derrière juste vous
avez un métier non derrière dans les
coulisses que je veux dire on connaît le
show bizarre moi je viens pour dire
on sait très bien qu'il y a certains
Bouchez voilà
ça veut dire quoi de cuissage
parce que c'est comme dans le médical je
suis désolé il du droit de cuissage
alors c'est pas mon père est médecin
donc
ce que je veux dire
il faut trier il y a des histoires qui
sont vraies et des histoires qui sont
fausses je ne dis pas que les actrices
ont tort et qu'elles disent des
mensonges attention je respecte je dis
qu'il faut laisser faire la loi mais pas
détruire les gens c'est ça ce qui s'est
passé en 2019 permettez-moi quand même
de m'exprimer c'est que que ça soit le
public ou le monde du showbiz parce que
quand tout va bien pour vous tout va
bien mais quand vous avez le moindre
petit problème on vous attaque demain
vous êtes plus personne le problème
c'est qu'on oublie les amitiés on oublie
qui sont les personnes réellement moi je
viens pour dire je ne dis pas que les
actrices sont des menteuses on est
d'accord je pense que la justice elle
est là pour faire son métier mais
j'aimerais que ça s'arrête même moi
aujourd'hui j'ai eu des menaces de mort
j'ai des gens parce que on me dit aussi
et on m'accuse en me disant mais vous
avez pas honte vous avez été agent
artistique de Thierry s’amitié je suis
son agent enfin j'ai été son agent parce
que il a des qualités professionnelles
et des qualités humaines et je suis pas
responsable moi mon métier c'est de
connaître de mettre des artistes de
l'ombre à la lumière et puis de les
garder à la lumière mais aussi mais mon
rôle d'agent artistique c'est être la
maman la seconde maman c'est ça mon
métier être la psychologue la confidente
et je viens je suis plus sous contrat
avec Thierry donc j'étais pas obligé de
venir et mon métier normalement c'est
être une femme de l'ombre pas de
m'exposer c'est pas mon métier de
m'exposer de dire à tout le monde
vous est-ce que vous l'avez trouvé
est-ce que parfois c'est quoi vous dites
il est un peu lourd mais Thierry il est
joueur il est draguer j'en connais plein
je citerai pas mais il y en a plein
comme ça
je non mais ce que je veux dire c'est
que maintenant on est dans une époque où
les femmes à force excusez-moi du terme
on vous donnera un jour porter la burqa
parce que même si on est en mini-jupe ça
va pas si on met on met en à l'aise
notre poitrine ça va pas et si un homme
va nous faire les compliments sur notre
poitrine excusez-moi je parle de de ma
personne par exemple ça y est les femmes
vont sentir agressées et du coup on fait
plus de compliments aux femmes parce que
on est dans un monde où tout est enfermé
ou c'est on a plus rien de grandir on a
plus rien droit de faire les hommes ils
ont plus loin
je suis entièrement d'accord mais
j'essaye de rétaliser je
ne AG donc je n'étais pas là sur les
faits
il faut que il mérite ça vous a étonné
vous êtes tombé des NU alors quand moi
je vous explique honnêtement j'étais
déjà sous contrat avec Thierry quand moi
on m'a contacté et qu'on m'a tenu
j'étais voir Thierry j'étais lui
demander qu'est-ce qui se passe on a été
boire un café voilà et là il ne m'a pas
menti il a déballé il a pas essayé de me
chercher voilà je sais qu'il aime bien
draguer les femmes voilà qu'il est lourd
parce que c'est un homme qui est un peu
farfelu qui très intelligent et puis
dans sa tête il est un peu dans sa bulle
un peu mais comprenez pas la même chose
de Patrick Poivre d'Arvor qu'il aimait
donc en fait après il y a une frontière
si vous voulez moi je viens parler de ma
place d'agent d'accord
donc je lui ai parlé le but c'est de se
dire qu'est-ce qui se passe de laisser
faire aussi la justice
c'est ce que j'ai toujours dit dans les
inter si vous voulez relisez 2019 et
vous a dit quoi alors quand vous l'avez
vu vous l'avez dit c'est Christophe
alors moi ce que je dirais aussi
au niveau des rapports du problème de la
production moi ce qu'il m'a dit
honnêtement c'est qu'il y avait un
problème c'est que la pièce ne
fonctionnait pas et qui avait déjà un
problème de mauvais entente entre tous
acteurs dedans je dis bien je n'étais
pas là d'accord je dis juste les propos
parce que attention il faut toujours
faire très attention à ce qu'on dit on
est d'accord mais quand vous lui avez
dit alors qu'est-ce qui s'est passé vous
a dit oui j'étais au loin avec elle ou
pas du tout alors moi il m'a dit que
c'était toujours sa façon de faire de
draguer de sa façon il me dit voilà tu
sais Vanina je suis il a jamais nié
qu'il était lourd d'accord parce que
c'est son tempérament d'être lourd
d'être mais moi bon le coup du sexe pour
les réaction
il m'a pas dit qu'il l'avait niait parce
que c'est un sujet qu'on a pas parlé ou
une fois il m'avait dit mais non c'est
pas vrai
les bisous pendant les représentations
il met la langue il m'en a pas parlé
voilà
que il soit lourd à faire des paroles de
drague très lourdes pas voilà c'est dans
son tempérament
donc ça a toujours été ce qui s'est
passé comme en 2019 parce que j'étais
son agent à cette période là
moi j'ai essayé de prendre contact avec
Monsieur Franck Leboeuf
c'est pas parce que je suis son agent
alors en privé pour lui demander
qu'est-ce qui se passe qui normalement
ils défend les femmes Monsieur Franck
Leboeuf champion du monde de foot c'est
très bien cela jouait dehors
quand une femme qui lui dit voilà je me
présente je suis l'agent artistique de
Thierry Samitier donnez-moi votre
version je voudrais discuter avec vous
et qu'on m'envoie des messages que j'ai
toujours
ou c'est pas du tout un tempérament je
pense que voilà je pense que là il y a
aussi une guerre de
avant que ça soit étalé au niveau voilà
avant qu'il passe venir tirer s'amitier
ici d'accord donc tout simplement
c'était pour savoir qu'est-ce qui se
passe mais juste Thierry Monsieur Franck
Lebas et je n'ai rien contre lui mais je
pense aussi que il faut savoir rester
neutre et se positionner sur
l'emplacement de tout le monde et
peut-être qu'il voulait peut-être qu'ils
voulaient réserver sa parole auprès de
la police il y avait pas encore de dépôt
de plainte
il y avait deux mains courantes et dans
ce cadre-là
une main courante pour relater les faits
voilà tout simplement
il avait du Sud il a du succès avec les
femmes Thierry bah honnêtement
comment vous dire
cette question qui se pose aussi en vrai
les mecs c'est vrai on se pose la
question je connaissais et je connais ça
[Applaudissements]
non non mais là il est accompagné d'une
très belle femme dans sa vie
après moi mon métier c'est agent
artistique c'est de connaître mes
artistes d'accord professionnel je
connais aussi personnellement
après ils font ce qu'ils veulent de leur
vie à côté bon bien sûr quand ça dépasse
les limites non c'est pas bien là
c'est je fais mon métier d'agent
artistique et quand après parce que
j'étais son agent on me détruit pour
dire parce que je suis son agent
depuis cette histoire
des contrats la décontra plus cette
histoire
même un producteur ah mais avec les
autres ça a été très difficile alors par
exemple on va en parler vous avez un
chroniqueur Jean-Marie Bigard qui me
connaît très bien une fois on a fait un
vidéo on mangeait ensemble excusez-moi
je connais GTA son restaurant manger
ensemble on a fait une vidéo il a appelé
ma fille ce qu'on avait des projets avec
Jean-Marie on rigole bien vous
connaissez je passe des moments tout de
suite les gens paf c'est on n'a pas le
droit parce qu'on est dans dans le
showbiz ou dans une personnalité
publique on n'a pas le droit de rigoler
de discuter parce que tout de suite par
exemple Jean-Marie c'est à traiter
d'alcoolique ou des choses comme ça moi
aussi j'aime bien boire j'aime bien
manger ça se voit non juste ce que je
veux dire c'est que c'est pas parce
qu'on est des personnalités publiques
qu'on a pas le droit à vivre après les
erreurs même personnalité publique on
doit faire face à la justice voilà et
que
la vie des gens à côté c'est qu'il y a
eu des faits répétés que des l'émetteurs
en scène l'ont prévenu que même sur les
chers voisins étaient il a été recadré
et que malgré tout malgré tout le récit
dit vrai c'est différent
mais on le sait tous qu'il est Lourdin
non mais c'est dans son attitude je vais
pas vous mentir vu que pour certains
vous le connaissez aussi mais c'est le
bon gars c'est pas quelqu'un de méchant
la jeune fille la jeune fille elle a
vécu un enfer apparemment
je dis bien que pour moi attention ne
faites pas dire si c'est passé vraiment
quelque chose il faut laisser faire
l'enquête et puis il faut laisser faire
la justice et puis Laura ce qui mérite
tout simplement enquêté depuis le dépôt
de plainte depuis un an et là ils
estiment avoir assez d'éléments pour
confronter monsieur Samitier donc on
rappelle la présomption d'innocence il y
a un grand écart entre le contenu de la
plainte et ses déclarations à lui et
celle de son avocat puisque son avocat a
toujours nié et contesté les gestes
inappropriés que lui annie est
totalement donc l'écart est-elle qui a
besoin d'une garde à vue aux yeux des
enquêteurs pour faire la lumière sur la
ferme voilà donc présomption d'innocence
mais un témoignage circonstancié une
plainte sérieuse et c'est pour ça que
les enquêteurs vont faire toute la
lumière au fil de la garde à vue sur ce
qui s'est réellement passé et sur les
suites à donner ou pas à cette affaire
voilà d'accord
je n'ai jamais dit que les plaintes
n'étaient pas assez d'argent
je ne suis pas contre non plus les
actrices parce que si c'est des faits
réels ça le mérite pas mais je pense que
moi ce que je viens c'est dire que dans
le domaine showbiz comme du même du
public de faire la part des choses voilà
chacun fait son métier moi j'ai fait mon
métier de défendre tirer s'amitier ça
c'est toujours bien passé voilà il y a
eu des hauts et des bas comme tout les
artistes les agents parfois on se prend
la tête voilà c'est tout à fait normal
c'est notre métier mais faire la part
des choses voilà Thierry il a aussi une
maman il a une sœur
voilà il est présumé nos 100 il faut
attendre voilà parce que il faut pas non
plus parce que c'est vrai qu'elle le
jugement médiatique comme on dit un pro
cès médiatique et c'est vrai que
derrière c'est très compliqué de se
remettre aussi donc voilà on fait pas un
procès on dit juste l'effet ce qui lui
reprochait pour l'instant on a bien dit
qu'il était il y a une présomption
d'innocence